and see like this is the thing a lot of
these reaction channels will try to
nitpick and they'll be like well if
she's working the chores are going to be
hard guys marriage is supposed to be
hard
um and I've told this story like many
times on my channel so I'm just gonna
tell it again
um there's a relative of mine and um
this relative was married for 50 years
and um this woman did not believe in
divorce like it it was just not an
option in her book and her husband
actually left the family for another
woman and she she prayed to God for a
solution because that was her belief she
did not believe in mayor sorry she did
not believe in divorce so her husband
leaves and the side chick died now I
know everyone's gonna say she killed her
I swear to God I swear she did not she
did not but this is the thing like he
came home and she didn't throw it over
his head she asked where they went wrong
in the marriage and how they could fix